hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a hyper modern defense
against the e4 opening and that's the
Alec on defense and it continues with
Knight to f6 development move for the
knight attack in the center and what
black hopes to do is allow white to gain
the center control with his pawns and at
the same time he is not going to move
his pawns toward the center he's going
to try to control the center with his
minor pieces and undermine the situation
that white has in the center so we're
going to look at the three main lines
that you may see the four pawn attack
the exchange variation in the modern
attack which is the main line and talk
about some of the key points that you'll
want to know for each variation the
first line that we're going to take a
look at is the four pawn attack and it's
the most aggressive line that you'll see
from white and what it looks to do is
control the entire center with its pawns
while trying to chase the Black Knight
all over the board
so it continues with pawn to d5 Knight
to d5 pawn to d4 and black spawning with
pawn to d6 trying to one give a little
room for his LightSquared bishop and at
the same time trying to undermine this
pawn on e5 that's already in our camp
here as you can see this is going to be
a common theme that's set up right here
and this is where all the lines are
going to vary from this situation right
here and in this case why it's going to
continue to put more pressure on our
knight and continue to chase our knight
around the board with pawn to c4 this is
three pawn so farm we're going to bring
our knight to b6 and why it's going to
continue with pawn to f4 and this is the
four pawn attack and as you can already
tell this is the most aggressive because
white already has four of his pawns in
the middle of the board controlling the
center we've only moved one pawn and
we've had our Knight chased around the
entire board the whole game which if you
know anything about opening principles
you really don't want to move your minor
pieces all around the board but any
hyper-modern player will tell you that
you want white in this case to
overextend his pond so
that black can undermine and take
control of the center later on the game
but black really has to be careful not
to play too passive because why it's
going to run over him if he doesn't
counter-attack at some point in the game
so just something to think about if you
are playing black that yes you play
passive at the beginning but then you
don't play passive later on you actually
play very active later on so sometimes
the think about now in this case black
has two different moves he can capture
with D takes on e5 or he also has a very
sharp line of g5 right here in hopes
that White's going to capture on g5 and
then after we exchange here on e5 and we
trade off Queens why it's going to be up
material by one pond but as you can tell
the White King can no longer castle and
all three of these pawns in the center
are going to be really hard for white to
defend and they're going to be very easy
for black to attack black can bring his
bishop into the action and once he
brings his knight into the action his B
Knight he can Castle queenside and he's
going to have a lot of attacking lines
and why it's going to have a really hard
game holding on to all these pawns and
protecting his King out in the middle so
this is the sharp line that you may see
and as we talked about another move is
pawn takes on e5 and from here after
pawn takes on e5 then we can bring our
knight to c6 attacking both this pawn on
e5 and d4 great development move for
black trying to control the center from
here you may see Bishop bring his white
bring his Bishop to e3 trying to hold on
to this d4 pawn this is going to be a
huge attack as you can re tell we had
two attackers on at this night and our
Queen here
and now we're going to bring our Bishop
into the action with Bishop to f5 and in
this case we're really looking to bring
our Queen made it to d7 and Castle
queenside and really try to put a lot of
pressure on this d4 pawn so this is the
for Knight attack it is again the most
aggressive that you'll see from white
but you may not see it as often as the
other two lines so we're going to take a
look at those as well
the next line we're going to take a look
at is the exchange variation it's very
common if you ever do play back on
defense you'll see it quite often it
continues much like the four pawn attack
with pawn to e5 attacking our knight
Knight to d5 pawn to d4 pawn to d6
remember we said we're going to see this
setup many times before White's going to
continue with the three pawn setup with
pawn to c4 and after our Knight comes to
b6 why it's now going to exchange on d6
now if you're a very defensive player
you're not very aggressive and you like
sharp technical lines later on in the
game and you like to build up in the
center then I would recommend pawn takes
on d6 and from here blacks going to look
to put as Bishop is like toward bishop
on e6 and bring his dark squared Bishop
to e7 Castle kingside he's going to have
a very sharp and methodically defensive
game now if you're a very aggressive
player like myself and you want to avoid
the common sharp line that you'll see
many times from capturing with your epon
you can instead capture with your C pawn
with C takes on d6 now from here keep in
mind that since we have our pawns on e7
and d6 we're going to fee and care to
our Bishop on the King side this is
something you always want to think in
the back of your head if we have our
pawns on e7 and d6 and we've already
made a few moves in the opening we're
going to move our Bishop to g7 because
it's going to take two moves for our
pawns to get out of the way of our
Bishop so keep that in mind and again
we're going to try to attack this d4
pawn and that's another reason we want
to bring our Bishop to the g7 square
this d4 pawn is a very strong pawn from
white and we want to put as much
pressure on that as possible so from
here you may see play continue with
Knight to c3 great development move for
white putting a lot of pressure on the
center and from here as we talked about
before we're going to bring our pawn to
g6 and then you may see white bring his
Bishop to e3 putting another defender on
this d4 pawn now keep in mind you might
not see white play this way so if he's
not too familiar with capturing the
exchange of radiation with our C pawn he
doesn't put a lot of defense on this d4
pawn it's going to be very good for you
once we bring our Bishop to g7 we're
going to be putting a lot of pressure on
this d4 pawn so if he's not building up
his defenses if he's instead playing you
know his bishop out and then trying to
Castle kingside you may be able to take
this deep d4 upon a little easier than
you may have expected so from here you
may see the white rook come to c1 and
from here we're going to Castle kingside
you always want to Castle kingside
sooner than later
make sure your kings in a safe place
from here you may see white bring his
pawn to b3 trying to put another
defender on this c4 pawn remember we are
attacking it with our knight here
anytime we can bring our Queen into the
action with a move like Queen to c7 so
from here we're just going to bust
through the middle again we're trying to
attack this d4 pawn but at the same time
like we talked about before you don't
want to be too passive if you're black
and the alekan defense we've allowed
White's have a lot of tempo gaining
attacks early on chasing our knight
around
so eventually depending on where white
plays if he plays defensive correctly
then we want to bust up the middle
and we want to make sure that he doesn't
have all the central control that he
wants to with all his pawns so these are
some of the things you want to take a
look at in the exchange of radiation now
let's go and take a look at the main
line and the main line from the
beginning starts out the same as the
other two lines white comes to e5 our
Knights going to come to d5 White's
going to play pawn to d4 and we're going
to bring our pawn to d6 but from here
it's going to be a little bit different
White's going to bring his knight to f3
and this is the modern variation it's
the main line so you'll see it more
often than not now from here this white
knight is very very active he's gaming
so no control but at the same time he's
attacking and defending both the pawn on
e5 and this pawn on d4 so this is a very
strong knight right here and this is why
many times you'll see black bring his
Bishop to g4 pinning down this Queen his
Knights not going to move and many times
from here depending on where white plays
blacks going to trade off this Bishop a
lot of times you'll see players try not
to trade off their Bishop for Knight
early on since the bishop pair is
usually stronger since it's easier to
open up a game than it is to close up a
game but a lot of times a black player
in this position will trade off his
Bishop because that knight on f3 is so
strong so I usually don't recommend
trading off your bishop if you are
pinning it down I like to just pin down
that night button now kind of fence
actually recommend to trade off your
bishop for that knight on f3 since it is
so so powerful so this is one thing you
may see in from here watch she's going
to take back with this Bishop on f3 so
that's one variation that you may see
you want to trade off that night and
another one you may see instead of g4
you may see
pawn to g6 a lot of players instead like
to try to bust up the middle they
already have one attacker with their d6
pawn and from here they just try to
start to chip away at the center so
they're going to look to fee and Heather
their bishop to the g7 square Castle
kingside and then they're going to look
to try to attack the center control here
so you can again a lot of players from
here even if they do fiend keto with
their Bishop on the King side then they
may bring their Bishop out to attack
this knight on that three so it really
depends on which way you want to go but
these are some of the most common lines
you will see in the mainline so hope you
guys enjoyed the video on alkyne defense
if you haven't already please subscribe
if you haven't checked out the website
got a lot of great updates on it is
www.hs website calm please leave me any
comments let me know how the videos are
going and I'll see you guys next video
thanks for watching